it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning all ice will be on the
chancellor today to see whether he'll
put a spring in everyone's step by
helping hard-pressed families in his
mini budget out for the government this
morning the conservative mp mark harper
who will be with us shortly i'll also be
asking the shadow chief secretary to the
treasury pat mcfadden and the former
labour center chancellor john mcdonald
how they'd fix the crisis plus with
fresh reports that president putin's
forces could be stalling will be joined
by the ukrainian ambassador to the uk
vadim pushdaiko it is wednesday the 23rd
of march
i'll bring you the latest inflation
figures due any moment now as the cost
of living crisis continues to bite
affecting prices not just at the pump
but on our kitchen tables
all that as the chancellor prepares to
reveal his spring statement will he help
families by cutting fuel duty or raising
the national insurance threshold
missile attack rushing far from a ship
off the coast of sebastopol as the
pentagon warns of increased activity in
the black sea
a city destroyed
ukraine's president says 100 000 people
in mario paul are without food water or
medicine and under constant bombardment
i'm in central ukraine where the human
cost of war is evident on every single
street corner
a game of two halves william and kate
all smiles in jamaica but protesters
there accused the royal family of
benefiting from the blood sweat and
tears of slaves
mr william i see you love to dance with
the black people
and
you love to frolic but
speak some truth on this trip
speak truth for what it's worth
two years on from the first coveted
lockdown we ask the w-h-o the world
health organization what the future
holds
the party party is over world number one
tennis star ash bharti announces her
retirement aged just 25 in order to
follow her dreams
also ahead on the program this morning
could your local chippy be under threat
i'll be speaking to the president of the
national federation of fish fryers with
warnings a third could close in the cost
of living crisis
and
gulliver's travels we'll be speaking to
the scottish couple set to cycle around
the world on a tandem bicycle to raise
money for hospices across ukraine
[Music]
morning all it is a very big day today
as the chancellor prepares to reveal
exactly how he's going to help
hard-pressed families survive the cost
of living crisis there are reports he
could raise the national insurance
threshold or cut fuel duty and in the
last minute we have had the latest
inflation figures which will paint a
picture of how much more families are
going to get squeezed our business
correspondent helen ann smith is at the
petrol pumps where of course prices have
been skyrocketing good to see you this
morning helen and so in terms of
inflation what were we expecting and
what have we got
well neil we were expecting inflation to
be very big very significant in the six
months to february and unfortunately the
figures haven't disappointed inflation
up by 6.2 percent uh in the 12 months to
february that's actually slightly higher
than what economists were predicting and
to put that in some context remember the
bank of england liked to aim to keep
inflation at two percent so 6.2 percent
a hugely hugely significant rise there's
a few pushes a few factors behind this
that we know about food and household
services are really pushing up we know
about fuel and energy costs very
significant um as well
but this is a really worrying figure for
a couple of reasons not least because
remember this is the figure for february
and people have been talking a lot about
the war in ukraine and the impact that
that's having
on prices and of course that has been
very significant it's pushed up the
price of wholesale gas the price of oil
and all that will feed through
unfortunately to petrol prices and to
energy bills but remember the invasion
of ukraine only came right at the very
end of february and this is the figure
for february so
what happens in march what happens in
april when we know that the energy price
cap is already going up and bills set to
rise by over 50 what happens in those
months set to be even more painful even
more significant
than this figure for february uh some
economists have predicted that when we
get to april that inflation will be well
over 8 potentially even up towards 10 so
really really at worrying times indeed
and this will be playing heavily on the
mind of the chancellor today as he
delivers his spring statement at the
very intensity of this cost of living
crisis what was
happening today was only meant to be a
very short fiscal update just a few
numbers it's been expanded into more of
a sort of mini budget with proper
measures expected and that's because of
the severity of the crisis that people
are facing uh in their lives people
desperately
struggling to afford to make uh ends
meet remember there's other causes to
this as well uh certainly not just the
war for the february figures things like
the labour shortage that we've been
hearing so much about the problems in
the supply chain all of this stuff
feeding through to businesses that put
their prices up that have to pass them
on so very worrying times indeed for
lots of people
indeed helen and many thanks
we will of course have full coverage of
the chancellor's spring statement
throughout the day here on sky news our
live coverage starting
improper from 11 o'clock
and i am very pleased to say the
conservative mp mark harper joins us on
the programme mr harper a very good
morning to you um
and i hope you don't take this the wrong
way but when i was considering that the
list of names that the government might
put up for interview this morning yours
was not necessarily at the top of the
list and you will understand why it
wasn't that long ago that you were being
pretty openly critical about boris
johnson and perhaps his longevity i'm
just wondering does your appearance this
morning mean that you're back to being
bffs
no look it's very clear i obviously have
had some differences with the government
over the last couple of years about how
it's handled the kovid pandemic i would
have preferred we'd got the economy
firing on all cylinders a little bit
earlier than the government um and
obviously before christmas i led a bit
of a rebellion um about the restrictions
the government put in place but actually
i think that was the right thing to do i
think it meant the government held its
nerve uh over christmas
and we've seen that the figures have
remained the same we've got the economy
firing on all cylinders and thank
goodness we did because it was only a
few hours between getting all of those
restrictions lifted
and then we saw the appalling russian
invasion of ukraine and we've gone from
one crisis straight into another which
provides obviously a very difficult and
challenging backdrop for the chancellor
um as he sets out his spring statement
later today yeah it certainly does but
at the same time you also did say
regarding the kind of the ongoing role
about partygate and who you what and
when in an around dining street you did
say that you wanted to wait for the
conclusion of the metropolitan police's
inquiry we are not at that point so
again i will say it does rather feel
that what is happening in ukraine has
perhaps to some extent shaped your view
of the prime minister
no i've been very clear on on the the
issues around uh how downing street
dealt with uh the so-called party gates
are i've said i'm prepared to wait the
prime minister wants us to judge him on
the facts i've said i'll wait for the
conclusion of the metropolitan police
criminal investigation which is ongoing
and the full sugree report when she
completes that and that's published but
that's a judgment i think for another
day we've obviously got this important
ukraine situation uh ongoing and the
government's obviously doing a good job
on leading uh opinion on that and then
we've got the very important spring
statement today so partygate hasn't gone
away but it's not first day it's for a
day in the future when the mets finished
its inquiry and the sugray report is
published
indeed well let's get straight on to the
economics of it all and as you're just
hearing we have had those latest
inflation figures cpi up from 5.5 to 6.2
percent certainly feels like we may well
be on track for 8 as predicted in april
do you think it's an inevitability that
we're going to hit double figures at
some point this year
well look i think what is certain is
that actually the economic picture is
very uncertain because of what's
happening uh in europe uh uh with the
ukrainian situation uh and i think
anyone who who thinks now they can
forecast what's going on in the autumn i
think is likely to be wrong i think what
it does illustrate
is the chancellor's got competing
pressures today he understands the
situation facing uh consumers and
businesses
but he also needs to make sure that that
inflation outlook the fact that interest
rate pressures are going upwards uh debt
interest is higher and he also needs to
build in some resilience to deal with
whatever the future may throw at us so
those challenges i think are all
competing um and provide a difficult
balancing act for today and i think
that's the judgment that i'm confident
that he'll get right when he sets out
his statement at lunchtime
of course we have heard from the chance
of you know facing quite a lot of
pressure over the the pending increase
to national insurance that that it will
go ahead that there is a necessity to it
i mean you would concede i'm sure that
the cabinet is not united on this
particular issue let alone the party i
mean is there perhaps some wiggle room
for rishi sunak and perhaps tinkering
with the threshold in terms of north in
terms of national insurance
well look i can't comment on on the
specifics of what's going to be
announced today but i think on the
national insurance rise it's very clear
we've said we're going to put an extra
12 billion pounds into first of all into
the health service to deal with the
backlogs that have arisen because of the
pandemic and then a long-term funding
central settlement for social care if
you're going to say you're against the
national insurance rise taking place
either this year or in the future you've
got to say whether you're prepared to
not put that money into the health
service or social care or come up with
some other way to pay for it people that
say they want to put off these rises uh
but still want to go ahead with the tax
rises and uh the spending increases are
just not being serious to labor for
example
that doesn't have money to play around
with but still
it's not as if the chancellor doesn't
have money to play around with i mean
estimates vary but we are talking about
tens of billions of extra revenue
sitting in the exchequer at the moment
well i think i think one of the problems
is everyone's looking at the the upside
points and there may well be i haven't
seen the forecast there may well be
extra revenue but i think people are
forgetting there are also extra costs so
there are cost pressures on public
services and also we've actually
obviously had to borrow a very
significant amount of money rightly in
my opinion to deal with the economic
impact of the pandemic but that means
the economy is vulnerable to rises in
interest rates
and inflation and we saw yesterday very
significant debt interest payments the
chancellor has to be mindful of that
when he's making decisions and you know
we were able to help consumers uh with
an announcement in february of nine
billion pounds to deal with a big chunk
of the rise in energy cost that was only
possible because the chancellor had some
resilience built into the system and i
think given the uncertain outlook for
the rest of the year i want to make sure
that there's a certain amount of
resilience built in so that we can deal
with whatever shops are thrown at us in
the future and the government can
respond to help consumers and businesses
cope with what the world throws is them
sure
a very specific question
from your perspective is this a point
where the chancellor could rely on on
extra borrowing or should we be using
these surpluses and there are surpluses
to start paying down some of the debt
well i don't think i think pretending
that you can continue
borrowing at the level that we have been
over the the pandemic i think just isn't
serious we borrowed for a one-off shock
which was the biggest economic shock for
300 years that was the right thing to do
to protect millions of jobs and
thousands of businesses that was
successful we've if you look at the
recovery from the pandemic we've got
some of the best numbers uh across the
world we've got a record number of
people on payrolls we've got very low
unemployment you know businesses have
started recovering but we've got to make
sure that we continue that sensible
economic management
and we build some resilience into the
system to deal with whatever the world
throws at us so i think the chancellor
i'm sure will look to help consumers and
businesses where he can
and is on people's sides but i think
he's also got to be mindful of very very
uncertain position coming in the future
and i think the public would expect him
to build that resilience and that
security into the public finances so
that he can look at dealing with
whatever problems arise in the future
yeah well i mean one of the one of the
things that the world in your words is
throwing at us at the moment is of
course the the the violence that we are
seeing in and around ukraine is there
not a really strong argument for a
significant increase in defense spending
at the moment particularly given the
amount of munitions material that we are
providing to the ukrainians at the
moment
well there is and of course we have had
that very significant increase in
defense spending uh in the budget that
was the largest uh increase announced in
defence spending over the next few years
uh for some time and of course the the
government's integrated review had
russia
as the top security threats sure that
that did that did rather precede the
violence in ukraine
yes it did but it recognized russia as a
threat it was a very significant
increase in defence spending and we
remain the second largest spender in
nato what's been very welcome of course
is that what's happened in europe has
meant that those european nations who
haven't been spending the two percent of
gdp which we more than exceed have also
now decided to increase
increase their defense spending and
what's important is that nato as a whole
has the resources and the funds to deal
with the threats we face so i welcome
those increases but we made a very big
commitment to defence spending in the
budget just a few months ago
um can we talk about um covet uh briefly
mr harper it's two years now since since
the first lockdown so many of us of
course have been affected individually
personally we will all know people who
have been ill many of us will know
people who have died and did we have a
rather brave 13 year old girl who'd be
on the program just a little bit later
this morning telling us about her her
father who passed away what lessons have
you taken away from the past two years
well i think first of all
it's been a very difficult year for many
people and a huge number of people have
had very very difficult personal
circumstances to deal with and i'm very
mindful of that
i'm also very conscious that
you know our
scientists and our health services
responded incredibly well so that we
could develop the vaccines get them
rolled out and we're now in a position
where with vaccines and the antivirals
that we've got we're in a position where
we've been able to enable people to get
back to normal
living with the virus it's going to be
with us forever it's not going away and
we've had to deal with that and i think
the country
individual people and some of our
systems have responded very well there
will be lessons to learn which is why
i'm pleased that the public inquiry has
been set up the chair of that inquiry is
consulting on the the terms of reference
they're very broad they'll look at you
know the government's decision making
the evidence how it balance things and
wage things up and i look forward to
that inquiry i'll be delighted to give
evidence to it in due course and it'll
set out you know when it reports uh the
lessons to be learned for the future
um we do have to let you go mr harper
before you do and you'll have noted the
the royals currently touring the
caribbean at the moment they've been met
by protests in jamaica plenty of anger
plenty of speculation that jamaica may
well be preparing moves to make itself a
republic i'm wondering given that it is
now the time for the royal family to
apologize for its role in benefiting
from slavery
no look i think the royal family leads
or sets out these things
very well when it goes on its tours i
don't think it's wise for the royal
family to get involved in politics
that's a matter for the government and
decisions about the future of jamaica's
constitutional status are a matter for
the people of jamaica and the government
of that country it's a democratic
country and that's right and proper i
think it's much better if the royal
family stays out of politics
and leaves that to the politicians and
they maintain that constitutional status
where they can unite the country and i
think from her majesty the queen
downwards in her jubilee year i think
the royal family do that fantastically
well
mr harper great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us
pleasure thanks very much neil cheers
bye-bye
uh let's take you through the front
pages that we have this morning and we
begin with the ft and according to the
pinking the chance that rishi sunak is
planning to set aside a large part of an
unexpected 20 billion boost to the
public finances this year rather than
using it to help families hit by the
cost of living crisis
here's the mail it focuses its attention
on calls for the chancellor to axe
what's been branded the worst timed tax
rise in history
the mirror leads with a plea for help
from a struggling struggling family to
the chancellor on the cost of the living
crisis
uh here is the guardian ashes of a dead
land reads their headline those the
words of ukrainian officials who accuse
vladimir putin's forces of
indiscriminate fire on civilians in
mario paul
as a mass exodus of the city intensifies
the daily telegraph reports that ukraine
has regained key territory forcing the
russian army to retreat in several
locations but raising fears that
president putin may soon turn to
chemical weapons
and here is the times it leads with a
rather less hopeful headline on the
ukrainian arsenal running low ukrainian
officials urging germany and france to
honor their pledges to send more arms
still to come on the programme as we
look ahead to the spring statement
labour's former shadow chancellor john
mcdonnell will be joining us that's just
after half past seven
we'll be joined by simon williams from
the rac to talk about what rishi sunat
can do in his spring statement to
address the rising cost of fuel
and two years on from the uk going into
its first national covert lockdown we
will be speaking once again to david
nabano from the world health
organisation
[Music]
but before all that ukraine's president
has accused russia of sabotaging efforts
to evacuate civilians from the besieged
city of mariupol
vladimir zelinsky says 100 000 civilians
remain there with no foods no water no
medicine
and of course under constant bombardment
the mod says that russian forces remain
static in the north of ukraine and are
likely reorganizing before launching
another large-scale offensive western
intelligence says the russian military
is also attempting to envelop ukrainian
forces in the east of the
country the ukrainian agency responsible
for chernobyl says that russian forces
have destroyed a laboratory at the
nuclear power plant that's responsible
for the management of radioactive waste
and president biden is expected to
announce new sanctions against russia
when he visits brussels for a nato
summit
sky news has verified this video taken
off the coast of sevastopol the largest
city in crimea it shows missiles being
fired from a ship not too far from
harbor pentagon spokesman john kirby
said in a briefing monday that the u.s
has seen increased naval activity in the
northern black sea
well these are the latest satellite
images from max r tech
showing the extent of the damage on
apartment blocks and factory buildings
in mariopol
smoke can be seen in several of the
images with fires continuing to burn in
others
the southern ukrainian port
has become a focus of president putin's
due to its strategic significance
skies john sparks is in dinipro and
joins us this morning
john good to see you um i suppose the
best the best thing to ask you is an
update as to the very latest we've just
had the mod briefing suggesting that in
some parts of the country the russians
are regrouping preparing for it for a
large-scale assault in other parts of
the country of course it just feels like
you're under a constant assault already
yeah good morning neil i i think the i
think the mod are right certainly from
our travels we've just come
back to tanipro from the city in the
northeast called harkeef large city very
close to the russian border
and it was clear to us that the russian
assault has significantly slowed their
military is essentially parked in the
northern suburbs of that city with both
sides essentially taking pot shots at
each other
from the woods clear to us that their
their advance has significantly stalled
i think it's also clear that the
russians have taken significant losses
in terms of in terms of personnel in
terms of equipment as well but there is
intense fighting going on actually not
very far from here about 200 kilometers
to the north east of dunipro in a city
called ism it's in the the harkai harki
region the harkeef state it's a small
city stands on the banks of the saverski
donetsk river
intense fighting over the last couple of
days ukrainian troops trying to hold the
western bank of that
river and there are also reports
unconfirmed reports of very heavy
russian casualties as well again
with a note of a real caution but they
are in circulation reports of 400 dead
russian troops again have to be cautious
about that
in the southeast in mario paul
you know the horror continues uh there
i think the name of that city will live
long in infinity 100 000 people
according to the russian uh to the
ukrainian president zielinski a hundred
thousand people in the center of that
city without food without water without
any services the fighting raging around
them a small number of ukrainian troops
essentially fighting to the death in the
middle of that city we understand that
about 7 000 people got out in a sort of
ad hoc convoy or a series of ad hoc
convoys uh yesterday those people taking
their lives into their own hand taking
the lives of their families into their
own hands when they make that decision
to leave the city
and the ukrainians said they tried to
send a humanitarian convoy
into that city with the prior agreement
of the russians the ukrainians say 11
buses got into the city and then the
drivers of those buses the emergency
services workers on board were then
taken prisoner by the russians so
really a very bleak situation down in
mario paul
john thanks very much indeed
um a little bit of breaking news
reaching us out from inside at the
kremlin uh dimitri medvedev a name you
will probably remember formerly
president of russia during one of those
brief periods when vladimir putin became
prime minister
he's been talking he says this the west
has acted in a disgusting criminal and
immoral way in relation to russia the
war of words clearly continuing
well let's turn our attention to royal
news show and prince william and kate
have been greeted by protesters in
jamaica they're demanding an apology and
reparations for slavery at just a
warning this report from our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills in jamaica
does contain flash photography
[Music]
for four days they've been cleaning up
trench town ready for william and kate
to walk into the birthplace of reggae
and into a country questioning what
their future relationship with the royal
family should be
looking in it's not a debate at the
front of everyone's mind yeah mr lewando
queen to be my queen i bonded july and
jamaica get independent the argos so i
want the queen to still be my
my representative here yeah we all feel
great about it you know you're coming to
trench you get me
yeah
so that's it
many indifferent just here to enjoy the
spectacle and see other jamaican stars
like england footballer raheem sterling
for you growing up how important was
jamaica's relationship with the royal
family and do you have much to say about
the debates going on at the moment
i don't want to devote too much into
that i think you know like like
if everything you have
some people that might be
you know
a bit frustrated things that happen in
the past but i think on the whole i
think there's a lot of love for the
royal family
a lot
these royal tours
of the fun always
but also the difficult diplomatic work
and the fact that they've got involved
isn't to downplay the big debates that
are going on issues that we understand
prince william is going to address in
the coming days before they'd even
landed protesters gathered outside the
british high commission demanding that
prince william apologize for the role
played by the royal family in slavery
mr william i see you love to dance with
the black people
and
you love to frolic but
speak some truth on this trip
speak truth for what it's worth
on his first trip here william is
expected to acknowledge the painful past
but stop short of an apology we wait to
see if that in any way can satisfy his
new audience rhiannon mills sky news in
trench town
well before heading to jamaica the duke
and duchess of cambridge took the plunge
to swim with sharks in belize uh this
video posted to their official instagram
page shows the royal couple uh that's
william on the left no no that's the
shark uh well they're visiting the
world's second largest barrier reef to
see ocean conservation work being done
there in the video prince william
praises the conservation efforts of the
belize government and local communities
looks like a fantastic little trip for
those two
now
two
years ago today can you believe it
this happened
from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home
because the critical thing we must do to
stop the disease spreading between
households
that is why people will only be allowed
to leave their home for the following
very limited purposes
it feels a lot longer but it was two
years ago today that the country went
into its first national lockdown to mark
the second anniversary a series of
events will take place across the uk
it comes as a comprehensive analysis of
excess deaths in england and wales has
revealed that covet caused fewer
fatalities than in many other european
nations our science correspondent thomas
murr has more
people haven't just died during the
pandemic because of the virus they died
of other causes too and that's made
clear by the most complete analysis so
far of excess deaths according to the
office for national statistics almost
134 000 more people died up to the end
of last year in england and wales than
expected from the five-year average much
of that rise has been in men up more
than 17 in women the rise was just under
11
now if you look at the timeline you can
see how excess deaths have fluctuated
above and below the expected level which
we've zeroed on the chart
you can see big peaks in april 2020 in
the first wave and in january 2021
during the second but strip out deaths
due to coronavirus and the results get
more intriguing so there was still a
peak in non-covered excess deaths in
that first wave here in light blue
probably because of a lack of testing
meant some deaths really caused by the
virus were attributed to other medical
conditions on the death certificates but
excess death from other causes dipped
sharply during the second wave probably
partly because lockdown meant flu and
other respiratory diseases were at low
levels they then rose again and remained
high for the whole of the second half of
last year probably because those
respiratory diseases got going again in
the autumn and lots of people were
vulnerable
overall looking at the whole period
there were almost seven and a half
thousand fewer non-covered deaths than
you would expect what really stands out
is the difficulty people with underlying
health conditions had in accessing
health care for example deaths from
dementia and alzheimer's rose 71 at home
but they fell 31 in hospitals and deaths
from colon cancer rose almost 37 at home
but they fell almost 19
in hospices when you look at a map
there's lots of variation in excess
deaths but no obvious geographic pattern
and no clear link with deprivation but
there were slightly more than expected
in rural areas and slightly fewer in
towns and cities so how does all this
compare with other countries well
earlier this month a study in the lancet
medical journal looked at excess deaths
around the world and they found the uk
ranked ninth in western europe with a
rate of just under
127 per 100 000 people rates were higher
in italy and spain but slightly lower in
germany and france the pandemic has
taken a dreadful toll on most countries
and understanding the statistics will be
key to learning the lessons
thomas murr there now i thought i'd
stretch my legs uh to show you a couple
of the stories that have grabbed my
attention today um let's take a look at
this in the garden uh that it's carrying
a special report on alicia uzimanov the
russian oligarch once said to be the
uk's richest person he claims to have
placed hundreds of millions of pounds of
his assets into an irrevocable trust
potentially leaving them outside the
sanctions regime established by the uk
the u.s or the western government he is
said to be connected to at least six
luxury properties in the uk
and one central london office building
now collectively we are told that all of
those buildings worth more than 170
million pounds
a slight change in tone do you take a
cheeky nap when working from home never
at the sun reports on a poll suggesting
that staff switch off around three times
a week wouldn't happen on the sunrise
breakfast team at the research also
found people take to social media for a
scroll around nine times every day i
think it's a bit more than that for us i
suspect uh and they also send non-work
related messages eight times a day yeah
i think i might be slightly higher than
that total but also in the sun this
morning don't look down um oh god alive
these are pictures of people posing for
selfies hundreds of feet up in the air
the woman in the center if you can just
about make it out that's not the pole
that's her friend whose shoulders she's
standing on on a pole but my reckoning
looks no more than two foot wide
rather them than me
anyway ahead of the spring statement
later today the former shadow chancellor
john mcdonnell will be joining us after
this
[Music]
[Music]
the surge in prices is squeezing all our
finances with rising fuel costs
inflation and higher food bills
the cost of living is going up and up
how will the chancellor's spring
statement help reduce the cost of living
crisis
the spring statement on sky news
welcome back just a reminder as to our
top stories and inflation has risen to
6.2 percent as the chancellor prepares
to give his spring statement the uk
facing the greatest cost of living
crisis in a generation
ukraine's president has accused russia
of trapping thousands of civilians in
inhumane conditions in the besieged city
of mario paul
two years on from the first coveted
lockdown the uk will be holding a series
of events
[Music]
well ahead of the spring statement later
today the chancellor is facing calls to
ax the planned hike in national
insurance as families face a cost of
living crisis i asked the conservative
mp mark harper whether there were any
plans to tinker with this
economic picture is very uncertain
because of what's happening uh in europe
uh uh with the ukrainian situation uh
and i think anyone who who thinks now
they can forecast what's going on in the
autumn i think is likely to be wrong i
think what it does illustrate
is the chancellor's got competing
pressures today if you're going to say
you're against the national insurance
rise taking place either this year or in
the future you've got to say whether
you're prepared to not put that money
into the health service or social care
or come up with some other way to pay
for it people that say they want to put
off these rises
but still want to go ahead with the tax
rises and the spending increases are
just not being serious
as you can see tomorrow cohen joins us
in the studio good to see you this
morning um but we just heard mark harper
saying you're if you say you are against
the the national insurance act there are
plenty of people that are against the
national insurance hike within the
cabinet and within the conservative
party there are plenty of tourists who
are against the national insurance hike
one former cabinet minister told me it
was suicidal to go ahead with it given
the pressures of massively increasing
energy bills we know they're going up by
700 pounds this year and inflation
rising the cost of everything in the
shops as well the chancellor has said he
understands the acute spending squeeze
on households but we've had two years of
big spending during covid we're not
hearing him saying today he's going to
do whatever it takes as he said during
covert to help people out of it but he's
announced a lot of support for energy
bills already we're expecting some more
support today i think most tories don't
expect him to scrap the national
insurance hike perhaps change the
threshold to protect people at the
bottom end also some action probably on
fuel duty as well there's talk of a 5p
cut although whether that's enough
really to touch the sides of how much
extra money people are going to be
paying this year is the question he says
it's all about security and making sure
we have enough money there in case of
massive oil and gas spikes later this
year thank you very much tc
uh someone with a view on all of that
i'm sure the former shadow chancellor
john mcdonnell at john's is live on the
program mr mcdonald it has been a while
so i do hope you're well
very well very well good to speak to you
again
so let's talk at spring's statement if
you have a crystal ball in front of you
you may well consult it but also you
might have a wish list what do you want
to see from the chancellor today could i
just address mark harper's point because
i think he's made a valid point i i'm
not i would like the national insurance
rise scrapped but you have to say where
else you could find the money for the
nhs and social care and a number of
think tanks including the tuc did
recommend to the chancellor at the time
what you can do is basically
tax wealth at the same rate as your
taxing income so in other words tax
capital gains tax at the same rate as
income tax and that would bring in the
estimate 17 billion so actually it would
be ideally suited to cover the amount
that the chancellor would want to raise
that's just as an aside because i
thought it was important that mark made
that point that if you are going to
scrap something you've got to replace it
with something else and i this could be
the way in which you have a fairer
taxation system well the first step
towards anyway
i think the most important thing for me
is you've got to protect people you've
got to inflation proof first of all
those people are going to be hit the
hardest in this coming months and their
people on pensions and benefits but also
the low paid as well and therefore
you've got to inflation proof
increases in pay as well that's the
first thing the second
i do think it is about controlling
prices i think we need to make sure that
we're capping the profits made by the
energy companies we saw the figures from
the think tank commonwealth that
identified the profit rates of some of
the energy companies as 42 45
in addition to that i think we need to
look at other prices that we have to
control
the the mayor for london sadiq khan has
said let's have a rent freeze i called
for that last year i think rent controls
are part of it and andy burnham up in
manchester making sure now he has
control over buses we make sure that we
prevent fare increases as well so
packages like that where we protect
people's incomes inflation-proof them
then also reduce an element of the costs
that are falling upon them i think is
absolutely key the other issue for me as
well and
i do criticize the government for this
over a long period of time that we need
to go for green growth and the first
step on green growth in the way in which
we can help people with their energy
bills is insulation we've been calling
for this for over a decade and if we
could have
capital investment in insulation
programs now it would increase the
number of jobs that we got the
predictions by about 450 000
it would insulate people's homes and
reduce their energy bills i think that's
the sort of package i'd like to see
today and i think we've got to recognize
how tough it is for people out there
therefore they need assistance now sure
i i think both you and i would agree
that if much if any of that gets into
the chancellor's statement today you'll
be a lucky man mr mcdonald but but i
wonder what your view is
of borrowing right now i mean you and i
spoke an awful lot back when you were
shadow chancellor and you often got
criticized with that phrase you know the
magic money tree you know given what
we've seen over the past couple of years
in terms of borrowing i wonder whether
you somewhat feel that your stance was
has been vindicated
well it has but you know
i told you so isn't it a particularly
good phrase to be honest i want to look
to the future i think what we've got to
do is make sure that we're responsible
in everything that we do and the
responsible way forward is to recognize
that in times like this
there's real hardship out there people
are suffering we're talking about people
it is true people choosing between
heating and eating we're talking about
people who've had their wages virtually
frozen for nearly 12 years it's tough
out there so yes we've got to protect
people in this short term and that does
mean an increase in borrowing in the
short term but the most important thing
is i said time and time again in our
interviews you borrow to invest and
that's why investment in alternative
energy sources in insulating our homes
is the right thing to do at the moment
because you'll reap such huge rewards
and actually in terms of energy and
alternative energy sources and
insulation you'll reap them pretty quick
as well sure mr mcdonald
given given our previous conversations
you might not be happy about this but we
whenever we have talked we've always
ended up talking about what's going on
within within the labour party and so it
is again today
recent recently of course you did pull
out of the stop the war rally after
pressure from the leader's office
because of their stance over you know
the extent to which nato is responsible
responsible for for what is going on in
ukraine
were you entirely happy to withdraw from
that event and genuinely what is your
view of the extent to which nato is
responsible uh from stop the war's
position for what we're seeing
i would drew my name for the statement
and withdraw because the the leader of
the labour party said so
and i because also the statement was out
of date and the i said then you know
we're in a war situation what we don't
want is internal political debates and
discussions like that and it would be a
complete distraction from the focus that
we should have on securing peace we've
got time to debate the issues around
nato and russia and the long term
what we've got to do now everything
every word we use now has got to be
about securing peace and we shouldn't be
distracted from that we too many people
are suffering at the moment so that was
my focus then it's my focus now and
remember
people seem to forget i was one of the
people who helped set up the ukraine
solidarity campaign over 10 or 11 years
ago we were campaigning with ukrainian
trade unions and others trying to secure
the long-term democratic future of the
ukraine i think that's the issue for me
now and i think there will be a time
when we debate the security system for
the whole of europe in the future what
will reassure people what will give us
peace now i think the focus has got to
be on securing peace yeah unfortunately
we are out of time so we can't even
debate it here john mcdonnell good to
have you on the program once again do
take care
thank you
now of course with the cost of petrol
reaching record heights all eyes on
rishi soon at later today to see what
provisions he puts in place to help ease
the ongoing cost of living crisis let's
speak now to simon williams from the rac
simon good to see you this morning uh
you of course taking the leo for the
lead for the rac on fuel it's pretty
horrific at the pumps at the moment
it really is uh neil the
average price of petrol is now 167
eliter and diesel at 179. 91 pounds to
fill up an average petrol car and 97 for
diesel uh the cost of living crisis is
being very much driven by the increase
in the price of the pumps um we are
calling on a chance to take action today
significant action he's talking about a
five percent fi p cut in duty which i
think will be a drop in the ocean that
will take us back to a price we played
this time last week uh what use is that
really i this is something but we need i
think he needs to go further in fact he
might be better off cutting v80 because
that's very much a tax on attacks on top
of the 58
pence elite we're paying in duty and
itself bringing around 27 28 peer liter
at the moment so
uh that five percent cut in vac would
actually knock seven pencil leads off of
the pump straight away uh and if prices
go higher he could go further too
just a random question that occurs to me
simon of course but the rdc has a number
of functions i'm just wondering if if
you are seeing people because of the the
prices at the pumps people avoiding
perhaps going to the pump for as long as
possible and you know breaking down in
increased numbers
we haven't seen an increase in uh
breakdowns in active fields people are
pretty good at that
but obviously people are and we know
from a survey we've just published today
that uh 25 of people
are saying they are having to cut back
on other things to put essential fuel
into their cars a third of people are
saying they're cutting out leisure
journeys because of the expense so this
is really starting to hurt and something
needs to be done to ease the burden we
know how important driving is to this
country and obviously the price of
petrol and diesel has really contributed
to inflation in so many ways everything
we have in our shops all the services we
have that come to our door everything is
moved by road and therefore petrol and
predominantly diesel
simon williams from the rac great to
have you on the program this morning
thanks for joining us
now the world number one tennis number
one ash bharti has announced her
retirement from the game at the age of
just 25. the australian at the top of
her game after winning both wimbledon
and the australian open within the last
eight months said that she was retiring
to chase other dreams
i'm
so grateful to everything that tennis
has given me it's given me
all of my dreams
plus more but i know
that the time is right now for for me to
step away and
chase other dreams um
and yeah and to put the racquets down
fox sports news reporter eloise sawyer
joins us now from sydney eloise great to
have you on the program this morning um
remind me we've been here before with
ash haven't we this one feels slightly
different though
yeah it certainly is a little bit
different absolutely incredible news and
to be frank with you we're still trying
to understand it the 25 year old's
announcement has come as a huge shock to
me and i suppose that's because of the
recent heights she's reached including
like you spoke of then the australian
open back in january and the wimbledon
last year and while her talent on court
speaks for itself it's the champion
woman and role model away from tennis
that makes us as australians so proud to
call her owls i mean she really doesn't
get any more aussie in the fact that
she's sponsored by vegemite she is also
featured in multiple advertisements and
campaigns for tourism australia she was
actually out at uluru one of australia's
most iconic and culturally important
landmarks after she won the aussie open
to help indigenous kids learn more about
tennis and inspire the younger
generation and as an indigenous woman
herself she's very passionate and
involved in assisting indigenous
communities and retire as that'll help
her in her retirement rather as for
what's next well she didn't reveal much
but as you said earlier she has actually
played qriket before here for brisbane
heat in the women's big bash league she
then returned to tennis and took it to a
whole new level and she's got a
fantastic uh crastastic career and also
too in golf as a husband so she's
certainly got plenty ahead in her
professional career but we will see what
lies ahead for ash body
louise many thanks
now two years ago this very day the
prime minister told us at home now on
the anniversary of the first covered
lockdown a series of events will take
place across the uk
joining us once again on the program dr
david nabarro the world health
organization special envoy for the
global covert 19 response dr nabarro
always good to see you and it it has
been a little while since we last
chatted which which usually means that
things have been going relatively well
with covid two years on from the first
domestic lockdown here in the uk
globally what's the picture like
well we still are in the middle of a
quite unpleasant pandemic
other things have dominated the news
recently but my quick summary is the
virus is continuing to move uh there are
still an awful lot of people getting
sick and dying each week
and we cannot be complacent i'd like to
ask everyone
do continue if you can to wear face
masks in crowded places do continue to
maintain physical distancing and if you
are vulnerable and that means if you've
got other diseases do please shield
yourself and the most important way to
do that is get vaccinated we're living
with the virus and it's still causing a
lot of problems
dr nabarro i don't know the last time
that you might have spent any amount of
time in london or anywhere else in
england right now it doesn't feel like
anyone or very few people are adhering
to those recommendations and they remain
recommendations for the government to
keep our distance to wear masks and
crowded places
people aren't doing it
yeah i've noticed that interestingly i
don't
i mean i'm more of the time in france
and switzerland and i have to say
certainly in france people are being
remarkably careful i'm told by my
children that it's a different situation
in the uk my only advice to everybody is
just don't forget remember that this has
killed so many people
and that it's still nasty i don't want
to get kobe and i don't think anybody
else should you know we're also learning
about long covid which is when you get
infected and you you think you're going
to get better and then you've got
several weeks of being unwell under the
weather unable to do what you want to do
here it is people are the solution to
this pandemic let's do what we can to
not let it get ahead of us again
i mean i was speaking to someone kind of
involved in the public health response
here in the uk you know a couple of days
ago but what does what does it look like
what does living with with covert 19
actually look like and they said look
it's going to be lots and lots of people
catching it some of those people getting
ill but
crucially very few people actually
losing their lives i mean is that what
living with covert looks like for you
i hope so but do you know get to reach
that point and to stay there
we have to all be up to date on our
vaccinations after you've been
vaccinated the defenses in your body
gradually fade and for some people older
people like me the fading is a bit quick
so i have to say to everybody keep your
vaccinations up to date you should
certainly have got three and perhaps you
should be thinking about a fourth if
you're in the older community and so
with that up-to-date vaccination with
being careful on not exposing ourselves
we'll live with kobe uh but if from time
to time we'll have a few scares
um dr nabarro i i want to ask you about
something that i saw in the papers the
other day and another vaccine that is
being developed at the moment the
world's first plant-based acting they
were told the reports suggested that the
who would reject that vaccine because
the company developing it is half owned
by the tobacco giant philip morris i
mean what is the truth of all of that
so i cannot answer that question okay
there are complexities there but i do
want to say to everybody new vaccines
are going to go on being developed from
lots of different sources and just we
need to be ready for real strides
forward in the whole area of vaccinology
including through the technology you've
described
just in terms of um testing do you still
feel that mass testing has a role in the
western world right now
well as i've said the virus is the
problem people are the solution you
can't solve the problem and live with
covert if you don't know where the virus
is and so if there's one thing i'd like
to ask all governments to try to
maintain
that is easy access to testing we always
say that if the proportion of people who
test positive in a country rises above
about 10
then there's not enough testing being
done there are many countries in europe
where there should be more testing done
in that way we know what's going on in
that way we keep ahead of the virus
dr david navarro always good to see you
i hope you and yours are well thanks for
joining us thank you thanks for having
me bye-bye
you guys can stay right where you are at
plenty more coming in the remaining two
hours of the program uh john is at the
top of the eight o'clock car as
inflation hits a 30-year high just of
course as the chancellor prepares to
deliver his spring statement later today
will there be any rabbits from that
we'll find out
[Music]
you